mahsa we have another question for you
that's very important and we've been
arguing about
so my niece who is a high schooler lives
with us we treat her like a daughter she
is somebody that we treasure she's also
just a very good she does bad friends
with she's also 18 years old she's 18
but she's still in high school she's
also she just came here from the
Philippines how long have you been here
Jules two years one year one year ten
months
oh she's right here yeah she did she
she's a CI dasu our friend so you have a
visual with the story you have a visual
hi oh wait how do I make your screen
bigger sorry wait can you guys say
something so that your screen is bigger
because right now alright sit back down
she's not like she's not like we were in
high school like I was sucking dick a
lot in high school in fact in fact um
you know you know why you had like a
school counselor and they're supposed to
teach you about that stuff right she'd
be like hey for starters how about stop
sucking dick and that's that's the
advice that I got from you know people
in school so she gave me that advice as
well she's not she's not like us okay
she gets straight A's she has a 4.0 she
does everything without having you know
without being told what to do she just
does it she's really good she's a good
girl she a good girl all throughout she
watches anime all day reads books
doesn't date doesn't really talk to boys
just crushes but you know like I'm like
so curious where this question how could
I possibly answer a question for a
person
the three of us weren't Disney kids
think of hers she's she's a Disney she's
a Disney girl she's a Disney teenager
the best um
so Bobby she helps Bobby on his other
podcast with Andrew Santino and she is
sort of the third mic but she's just
basically there to make sure that the
shows like running well and last week
Bobby started talking about her in like
making like sexual noises like
speculating on how she's masturbates and
things like that no I was saying this
okay she has let me defend myself well I
just want to say I believe kalila that's
why you're not a judge no career day for
you okay so okay but I want to hear
amazing what I was saying so she has a
um she's into anime an anime as well and
she she likes a character from one of
the animes an enemy called haiku high
q-- high q-- and what's the character's
name Kuro Kuro she has a crush on an
anime and a jolly ball player
so I said to Andrew you know at nights
right she's watching like anime no no
just finish I mean okay finish right I
have my time on the on the floor thank
you judge sustained man finish my on
point
so she's um you know that she's you know
at night watching anime and then you
could hear probably noises and she's
masturbating to enemy I got that thought
that would been a funny little but it
wasn't just a quick thing he went on and
on and on for like basically six
different times on the podcast he kept
on how is that any different than look
away with it
yeah you were making a show i'veseen law
shows right I've seen law shows where
the defense attorney right it's his turn
to go on to the you know the platform
however they say it and he you can tell
that he's up against you know I mean up
against it there's no really defense but
he tries right yeah I know your honor
that you know my client you know had you
know the victims um
dick in his mouth that he had severed
off right and then he had they found the
family underneath his house you know I
mean but um he really wasn't there I
mean they try to do a defense right so
that's what I just did
all right I had to defend myself the
question the question is like basically
I've you know she's 18 we've allowed her
to have this little like side job
I don't want it doesn't it doesn't I
don't want him to exploit her in that
way because I feel especially protective
of her because I do like I do take on
like a mother role and I feel like Bobby
should as well and for me to think that
a fifty year old father figure would
speculate about what his teenage
daughter masturbates to is creepy
but your honor your honor may I make a
point your honor man she's nodding Oh
doesn't matter your honor I have a point
and I just thought if the point your
honor
all right is is that it is not against
the law is it to do that right this is
law right this is yeah this is a we're
doing court thing okay hang on I just
have one more point to me no but if we
were talking about the law we wouldn't
even be talking about it on Tiger belly
exactly we're lawless but there are
certain laws within that lawlessness in
the wild wild west there are still
things that are acceptable and
unacceptable right so for me if you
don't inherently know if that's not your
instinct to say hey you know what I want
to protect my niece or my daughter then
you've got some weird Woody Allen [ __ ]
that you need to sort out not therapy
really
I'll try to sneak that in there only
because okay here this is where you'll
see that I am a fair judge because I
don't think it's fair to say to compare
you to Woody Allen because what do you
Alan allegedly like raped oh he did he
didn't just be better different look at
look at Halle playing innocent I'm not
sure if he raped or just like molested
even a side group woody woody allen also
that's his stepdaughter right adopted
honor right that he adopted right raised
right she was underage right and married
her and it's [ __ ] her difference
between talking about that one oh I was
wrong about Mia Farrow's kid oh all
right so anyway basically associated
Buffy so yeah but I I see what you're
saying though like kalila I agree that
it's it's it's unacceptable all right
fine
so I lost the I lost the the hearing and
I want to say this I will treat her like
she's a 12 year old girl right what I'm
saying you don't infantilize her I want
I would I would you get one or the other
either I treat her like my friends and
like my peers and like how I treat
everyone else or you treat her like
she's a kid there's a there's a way to
it I'm not doing this there's a way to
my thing is I don't I don't want to
protect her from the elements of life
like when I talk to her I want to
empower her sexually she's a growing
girl whatever I don't want to suppress
that about her I just don't think that
it's your place to publicly talk about
her squirting like that's just weird to
me it's not a factual thing that she did
it I was a hypothetical thing and I
wanted to defend myself to Andrew
Santino then said to the audience right
send her dick pics and then she got to
dick pics on her [ __ ] writing she she
should we had dinner the other night
uncle T don't look right
big nine-year old man's dick hard he's
just like right and she's getting those
[ __ ] pics how am I on the [ __ ] you
know in the guillotine and Andrew
Santino's not because Andrew Santino was
visibly uncomfortable when you were
making this birth noises he was just
trying to kind of come up with something
less like the lesser evil which big pics
really are pretty horrible but because
everyone can send them and it's it's
sort of this like it's it's not a
relationship between you as dad and her
as daughter it's a random stranger
sending an unsolicited picture of a dick
like that's not it's also likely he
wouldn't have said that if you hadn't
like made squirting noises exactly okay
you know what I just I just I realized
that my wrongs doing it who are you are
you framing yourself sir I realize my
wrongs doings alright I feel extremely
guilty for doing it and now that you say
that I want to legitimately become your
father and I'm your daughter
excuse me daughter right I'm your father
now you're [ __ ] her up you know she
has daddy issues too alright fine
honey what how does she feel about it
like does she Jules
um do you feel uncomfortable when he
when people talk about you in that way
and then you can't like protect yourself
or like have a come back be yeah yeah
well you were you offended that I you
had that animate be real honest
uncomfortable yeah so she says it's
uncomfortable but she also knows that
that's not what he means like that's not
what that yeah so yeah I know no I
totally get that because like I think to
know Bobby is to like not take those
things personally right yeah but also
like the reality is like you put it out
there for the world
yeah like that's still a fact all right
damn that is a fact
all right but but you also could I just
defend myself in this way I can fight my
way out all right
I had to fight my way out I've never
right been around children your honor
you're hotter I've never seen it I see
no color yeah it's like when Trump goes
here there's my african-american friend
yep it's like you're all right I
apologize I apologize your honor I know
my wrongdoing whenever the sentences I
accept it what is the sentence salsa I
won't be I will not do it again all
right
honestly Jules what you don't look so
well for her to even hear that weird I
know I know I know listen III you know
what I have to say something I do I
enjoy your company you've done so much
help around the house right you clean it
you put away my English muffins and
stuff and also I find you to be very
funny and a nice person and you know I
do love you and I and I I do view you as
um you know at least a nice you know I
mean like I like blood like you're a
part of my family so um I will never do
that again I apologize and I've changed
my ways I've just you know in a comedy
podcast I just throw things out there
you know and sometimes it goes awry
mm-hmm sometimes it goes awry and I
should have cut that portion out you
know damn Bobby you
what's going on with you you're like a
different person because I've been doing
therapy and you know we haven't seen
each other a lot of lots happened since
we last talked